on retrouve notre correspondante
Emmanuel chasse bonjour Emmanuel
l'Ukraine aussi revendique des succès
notamment en mer Noire et la péninsule
de Crimée annexée par la
Russie bonjour Damien oui tout à fait
vous avez mentionné cette attaque
nocturne par des drones russes 42 drones
lancés 32 interceptés par par la défence
antiaérienne ukrainienne ceux qui n'ont
pas été interceptés bien ils se sont
écrasés principalement sur le la ligne
de front principalement dans la région
de hson que vous avez mentionné mais
mais l'armée ukrainienne enregistre
beaucoup ces enregistre également ces
derniers jours beaucoup de succès vous
avez mentionné ces frappes en Crimée un
porte un un navire de de l'armée russe a
été détruit selon les affirmations de
Kief il transportait justement ces
drones que nous évoquions ces drones qui
jour après jour sont utilisés pour
bombarder le pays donc un succès
ukrainien qui s'ajoute aux C avions de
combat russes qui ont été également
abatttu lors de ces 5 derniers jours par
l'armée ukrainienne mais le commandant
en chef des armées Valérie zalouni qui
s'est adressé hier à la presse
ukrainienne a reconnu à demiot que la
situation était extrêmement difficile à
marinka dans la région de Donetsk il a
on va écouter ce que le commandant chef
avait à dire justement sur cette ville
de l'est de
l'Ukraine
Mar a résisté pendant près de 2 ans
d'abord rue par rue puis maison par
[Musique]
maison puis à ce jour nos troupes se
trouvent dans sa partie nord elles ont
préparé une ligne de défense à
l'extérieur de la ville mais je peux
dire que cette ville n'existe
plus pour ce point sur la situation
maisemu c'est pas la seule déclaration
du commandant chef de l'armée
ukrainienne revenu et bien sur
l'équipement de ces hommes ou encore sur
la question de la
mobilisation tout à fait cette question
de la la mobilisation elle est
extrêmement importante ici en Ukraine
d'autant qu'elle fait débat ces
dernières semaine après sa conférence de
presse de fin d'année le président
Zelenski avait affirmé que le commandant
chef des armées lui avait demandé de
mobiliser un demi million d'hommes
supplémentaires c'est une affirmation
qu'à réfuté euh Valérie zalogen lors de
sa conférence lors de sa propre
conférence de presse il a expliqué tout
simplement que le commandement en chef
des armées n'avait pas ce pouvoir
décisionnel de faire de telles demandes
directement au gouvernement ce qu'il
fait c'est qu'il participe à des
réunions de travail avec le ministère de
la Défense qui ensuite s'adresse au
cabinet par exemple comme il l'a fait le
25 décembre pour soumettre un nouveau
projet de loi de mobilisation il devrait
baisser l'âge de la mobilisation de de
27 à 25 ans certaines catégories qui
avaient auparavant été exempes de
mobilisation pourraient être appelé sous
les drapeaux alors forcément c'est une
question qui fait débat ici dans la
société ukrainienne ceux qui voulaient
se battre on sans doute déjà se sont
sans doute déjà engagés dès le début de
l'invasion à grande échelle de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine et l'Ukraine peine
appeler de nouveaux hommes sous ces
drapeaux alors que l'armée enregistre
des pertes puisqu'elle fait des
projections sur l'année prochaine pour
ses besoins non seulement en homme mais
aussi en équipement et en armement
Emmanuel chass depuis Kiev pour France
24 merci beaucoup Emmanuel